Once I started looking into my childhood
and doing the healing work
of trying to repair myself and deal with generational traumas,
I realized that a lot of my romantic relationships
were extremely toxic.
And I was drawn to narcissists and trauma bond relationships.
So when I saw this book, I went to TikTok Shop,
I immediately had to try and read it.
It is called Run Like Hell.
It is by Nadine Mcelousso,
which, if you're not familiar,
is The Wolf of Wall Street,
ex wife, the Duchess.
And what I liked about it the most
is that it tells you all about why you kind of
enter into trauma bonds, what they look like,
how to identify if you're in one,
and how to heal from them and try and get away from, like,
pathological romantic issues.
Finding these narcissists.
I highly recommend the book to continue on your journey,
either whether you're single
or you just wanna kind of understand your romantic past.
Because I know that I am now in a very happy,
healthy relationship.
But I had no idea why I was so drawn to these toxic,
narcissistic relationships before.
And this is a really good read.
You can find it in my TikTok shop,
or you can find it here on TikTok Shop.
Um, Nadine is also on here.
Her page. I'll tag her and you can go see.
She does great TikTok videos that have been really, really helpful.